hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
Renewables overtake gas this winter to
become the number one source of
electricity for UK homes
green groups urge the government to
stick by its commitment to ease the ban
on new onshore wind farms
and it's deforestation the cause of
reduced rainfall in the tropics
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now Renewables have generated more
electricity than gas this winter and
produced enough to power every UK home
for the whole season it means the
country is less reliant on gas Imports
which would have been over 22 percent
higher without the Renewable Power
those numbers come from the energy and
climate intelligence unit and their
energy analyst Jess Ralston joins me now
welcome to you Jess so just how
important a moment is this for the
environment but also in terms of energy
security
well what the analysis shows us is that
the older outdated Energy System which
as you say was very heavily reliant on
foreign gas Imports that system is
giving way to a modern system
um whose backbone is based on cheaper
Renewables
um which are from the UK so obviously
with energy security being a top concern
not only for the public but also for
politicians it shows that Renewables are
having a positive impact on our energy
security well yes there are many who
will still say that wind and solar are
intermittent forms of energy and they
say that we're always going to need
fuels like gas to bridge that Gap
but with Renewables what we're actually
seeing is alongside the Boom in
Renewables industry like our offshore
wind farms we're actually seeing a boom
in the battery industry as well so
large-scale batteries which can help the
grid to manage times where we have too
much electricity or we need a bit of a
boost and these batteries are rapidly
coming to Market and the pipeline is
actually up by five times what it was
this time last year and with it expected
to go another 14 fold in the future so
these batteries really are the industry
of the future we're going to see jobs
we're going to see growth and we're
going to see export opportunities from
them as well
but the truth is at the moment that the
UK is heavily Reliant still on gas isn't
it I think the IMF has suggested that it
supplies 40 of our power and 85 of our
heating so how does the UK compare to
countries in Europe or the US for
example on this use of gas
that's absolutely right there IMF has
come out and said that we are the worst
hit by the gas crisis because we're so
relying on it and that's as you say
because we use it for power we use it
for Home Heating and also our homes are
so leaky that actually a lot of the gas
that we do have to import simply escapes
through our leaky roofs and through our
leaky walls and that's something that
the whole energy industry has identified
needs to change as we come off gas and
simply to have that energy Security in a
better place and also to reduce our
carbon emissions while lowering bills
so how quickly can we wean ourselves off
fossil fuels and boost the use of
Renewables and what will that mean for
people's bills
well the more Renewables that we have
essentially the cheaper our bills will
get and it's interesting that you've got
a piece in a few minutes about onshore
wind because the government has said
that it's lifted the barrel on show wind
but it hasn't really effectively done
that yet because it's still subject to
this local consent issue
um and with that as soon as they they
you know have more and it was on the
system including answer wind people's
bills will fall and the government has a
Target to have a completely clean
electricity grid by 2035 so in 12 years
time we're expecting uh this change
should have happened so it's a really
exciting time for the Renewables
industry okay just for awesome
interesting to get your take on it
thanks very much indeed for that
so let's get more on onshore wind as
Jess was saying as well as the other
climate news now and the UK's main
source of renewable energy is wind power
and a group of Charities are urging the
government to change a planning policy
which they say is preventing the
building of onshore wind farms a
consultation on the policy closes today
and the government says it's exploring
giving local authorities greater
flexibility on whether wind farms are
built there well Leo Murray is one of
those who's written to ministers
only one in ten councils in England have
designated any areas as suitable for
wind energy so that means only one in
ten councils can approve a wind farm but
secondly you also need as the developer
to show that the the concerns raised by
the community have been fully addressed
and what that means in practice is that
a single objection to a wind turbine can
be can be used to block consent for it
the government's decision to allow
exploratory drilling for gas in the
Surrey Hills is being challenged in the
court of appeal today sorry County
Council originally refused UK oil and
gases drilling application but the
decision was overturned by the
government the discovery Discovery is
worth an estimated 123 million pounds
reduce rainfall across large parts of
the tropics has been linked to
deforestation that's according to
research conducted by Leeds University
which found that loss of tree cover
means less water is returned to the
atmosphere
just a reminder that you can watch the
climate Show with Tom Heat this weekend
he'll be in Scotland learning all about
the importance of Pete and how
traditional Industries like whiskey are
facing up to the damage caused by
digging it up that's on Saturday and
Sunday at 3 30 pm here on Sky News
and if you scan the QR code you can
listen to the latest edition of climate
casts you can listen And subscribe now
wherever you get your podcast from
thanks for watching that's all from us
today
[Music]